so I started to hear about three years
ago about three months into working here
as a native land was my first day to
science tell that I never had i'm
working on a brother and I think
wouldn't it be great to get some test
data so I'm thinking okay we have this
device traffic supposed to be sort of
cool way that I've been told that it's a
small household a large or see us leave
little island of the visor like well I'm
clever enough I'm going to Manderley
grab an advice I'll do something yes for
search I'll get all that if I connected
to and I'll have a nice samples that of
different components so are recording
everything moving great on my test
server and great I Spit on a life I get
the first cluster small reasonable
get the second cluster all going well I
get on the word Buster and just seems go
and I'm thinking like why is my job
taking an hour oh but not that bad and
then I stopped the code and I look at
the output I realized that I had
something like 10,000 no humility
discussed her and like going on I hope
this there's something seriously wrong
and that is when I coined the term
sharknado lesser you can see what three
years ago and the world
and so that's when we realize here at FX
that we wanted to understand the graph
we were going to have to figure out how
to solve the connected component problem
scale first I'm going to solve the
computer going to sleep
ok so I'm a data scientist they came to
talk about three years ago I've ever
ended in chemical physics so cut me a
little slack if I don't know the big o
of every algorithm I talk about I'm not
going to talk about classifiers I'm not
going to talk about a design I'm
actually going to talk about engineering
this is the perfect crowd for this fun
so I'm talking a little bit about tap
back cause I don't think anybody's it
the top of the marketing from lv forces
adtech what we're trying to do is n joey
is find a way to probable assume your
link to go across so you have phone you
have a computer we want to be able to
leverage information that we get from
our equals a single by your higher than
your phone ok you are interested in
buying
functional programming in gaol so you
put into your cart in some web page but
you never stop thinking about it a
little maybe I wanna buy for Apple some
ill-advised season so as you know he'll
buy it and then maybe we think that we
may be under self will be more
susceptible for something and then I'll
show you big shiny bad outcome is
amazing but this you should all diately
that's what the goals of it so the way
that we think about our losing it
doesn't graph we have for the nice wrap
its streamlined so there we are new one
hoping for the best and we try to
connect people with computers to each
other
the problem is a Jessica with you that
marley identity is really hard do you
have identifier persistence and accuracy
issues and we sing with lots of
different burner and some
sometimes also missing identifier for a
thousand and delighted that's not good
we have conflicting data sometimes
wasting the one of our cookie Dipper
particles they know actually think
that's two different how do we reconcile
that we have issues improving piece
which is exactly the problem and
ingratitude how do we define and
connected component camera we have
privacy issues you know we definitely do
not want to know that this graph
represents Daniel right now we want to
know this graph over the an entity
without a name social security number
and email address Arnie fingerprint
technology and then we need some new
capability cuz we're actually salary to
what the license idea dr. Toby I don't
know if it is commissioned but so I was
like what do you think
identify our persistence but consistent
in time and also remain connected to
phone apart I'm going to tell you of two
algorithms are you like and I think that
I found their use case three stages the
best Roman title that identify risk so
grooming you how can we effectively
groupies at the scale it up suck it and
then also how can we make sure that
those identify receiving a consistent in
time ok so I don't have any copper wires
I have no recommendation and no
communion section so I think that I have
to turn in my data science badge others
so this is what our graph looks like our
front-end engineers are very talented
and there's a very lovely medial evasion
and so what you can see is that since
the early days we have cleaned up our
sharknado issues and now our Clark did I
step really is made up of small
independent but the problem is that
there are 1.4 billion of them there are
six point six billion connection between
them and so how do we actually determine
these little sub graph how can I get on
by this book that you know 15 devices
are actually one so the road-roller
media the most vanilla version of the
message passing algorithm I can tell you
that it doesn't work beside databases
integrate technologies which claimed to
be able
serigraph and we have just not been able
to make it work for us so we had to grow
up and the current system that we do run
actually one of the water in the ground
fast the community and culture not just
our devices but all of the identifier
this DNA virus or area 15 times
four million ago the most amazing thing
thought of you in here so maybe some you
familiar
there's no background or data scientists
like myself we're not familiar with
label population in Iraq and then I go
through it the first thing you do is you
have a buster misterios cutter which is
just linear collecting the worst case
scenario for a little obligation you
just say I'm okay I'm very welcome here
I will assign myself and highway 1 so
the first round you get a b c d if you
had a temporary label and then in each
toxic around what's going to happen if
you were going to ask your neighbor
what's your label and decide whether or
not you prefer your neighbors label or
department and in this one we choose to
use the minimum so you will always
prefer them in the moment there we have
you had a b c d the eggs going to have
to be but hey is this moment of these
table be on the other hand is going to
ask a and C now we notices pee has a
better label so I'm going to steal a
single the csb md cc's that be have a
variable at that time that label is B
because this is happening right after
work it doesn't yet know and he is also
getting of that illegal and then last
but all these see you can ask e and it's
going to update this so in that round
will get a a and then the size of around
the a will propagate over the view
accommodate over a total whole cluster
has become a and then once there are no
changes from one iteration
and you know that you sufficiently Mabel
and you just give this cluster abell
heavy if you need because you only have
one year middle-aged that's pretty basic
regret that is very look if you have a
very long linear can be easily new to
sit there and actually do that you know
in a thousand rounds which may it won't
happen it would be very hard in
revolutionary because it we need 1000
every single time with you look for
dinner that's something you want to
place so we found this really cool paper
about finding everyone
rounds whatever engineers Garrett he was
very kind of say implemented for the
wrong house
so if the old algorithm to give you the
runs in the diameter of your chain
that's how I email the tape this one's
going to run the law today so it's
called a testament and i'll show you a
little bit about i like to do in the
pictures better that way so when you
initialize this until you have same kind
of set of you how these nodes and they
have their label and the first half for
every node V you've assigned the minimum
of Z and appears neighbors as its
current postulate and you also define a
cluster C of beef which is at the time
just the seven itself and its neighbors
so every facility is going to get legal
a he is going at flavel a he is going to
get beat it's almost like if I did the
first path with the previous and then
see me here is going to be different set
of neighbors of myself so a set is a
SI o SI de alright so the first half
round one so for each see me you find
the minimum value so for this guy's a
little I better better so you see a is
going to get and a is going to find the
name of a reason to find you a season
and so we figured that that's good but
then what we do is we broadcast see you
need so the whole set of a year to the
one that we've just down the middle so
see for example will broadcast this
entire set to me and then in place of it
will always as a record of where it
separately ok I'm going to give up all
of my data to the best candidate for the
label and in his place I will only
retain the information about where I
stood
so each node V then merges all of the
cds that I get so as I said penis and
all the didn't be so we will now have
all this magicians whatever has as well
as the minimum a beta cells but be in
the news I won't have sent all the
day-to-day routines only a but in the
same breath is receiving all of the data
from he think that it's the best again
so that's going to look like this what's
the update so a has now received the
data basically just want to eat the
beans actually received all the Nativity
and head to protein a and memory for
itself sentences clear
though and then we keep going you
continuously send all of your data to
your current minimum and so you have
everyone this has basically a pointer to
the top and you export all of your data
at the same time you backwards to
everyone so what's also happening right
and v is them so at the same time the
seat is sending all this in here to a it
also wants to tell me and me like a
trade of trailer very much by the way I
spank you to a so it's one of the
broadcast this value out together so
it's almost like it's sending the
majority to the middle
and then sending the best one to
everyone a sort of a trail back to where
it came from in both directions at once
this is exactly how you get the
logarithms because you're going got just
one directing your watch available okay
so you would end up completing a logger
in the ground and you end up ending when
nothing has changed the same exact
stopping criteria and standards a last
round then you see that a has all the
information in the other node now they
themselves to know where their needle
they know which node there any questions
about that yeah
cv in floor it's both some fancy sort of
a pointer and also the step that you
want so if you are you contain more than
one thing then you are probably isn't
inning through the list of all devices
upset if you're containing one thing
it's often represented a point so see me
for acting for jewelry it's in one
direction in the pointer and in the
other direction is actually the stack of
all devices in effect so when you finish
your algorithm if you have a viewer node
see and you see that you have
yourself in here you know that your
entire culture in a good point to this
to know that's where you look for the
members of that so that if you're not in
the cluster
so so what we have been thinking about
you have a second help so we working at
Tech and so we we build our dropping
everything service every week you build
our back while getting the data now the
problem is our campaigns they don't just
run in this paper
they were on the facebook
we really want to be able to track not
think what happened today but tomorrow
and yesterday and so doing that we we
need to find a persistent wait
so the current scheme that I just
described to you you just
alright so you have this cluster it you
CBE to take its minimum that a that's
our old way of labeling things we found
is that we
we have to be eight percent of devices
have attainable that's not something you
give yourself they don't like numbers
like the only person i think that's not
seventy percent is dropping off our
relief after eight weeks my posture is
labeling for any given device only have
about a one in five chance of being the
thing it's not good for following users
so why the twenty two percent of devices
change marriage bureau so there's two
classes and there are certain miss
classes i call the acceptable reason for
another change that idx grace you crazy
so in the ID space world you have
doctors that are you have devices that
are turning their cooking you have
people buying new devices so you have
all kinds are wings boy
notifier my entry order so you guys
think like a device expired so you see
in this can be it physically worn that
we too we have disappeared maybe turning
cookie maybe it's device that I
accidentally spilled tea all over a
little bit familiar with my children can
have it you'll know how likely that is
or you know your new oculus came out and
definitely we're going to serve you have
been advertising while you're playing
your very invertigo and using virtual
reality game and now a new way of
another graph and therefore the
conservation is also the torture of
these clusters have not fundamentally
changed just you got you there is a new
often do it and it's totally fine ok and
then
this is a little bit left out and that
you have proper splits now short of
occasional very bad by us we don't
really want to succeed in anything in
her very often for the mean that we sort
of made a mistake somewhere we make me
say it doesn't like to make too many
other or you have a situation where two
Buster's Martin to the opposite and as
much as you like to think of us
observing the good work a little cake
c-a we actually think there's probably
more likely a timely manner so what is
it between them but turns out actually
for the seventy-five percent of the
twenty two percent are the sort of
acceptable
created all devices going on the graph
only about three or four percent are
going out because what we call
unacceptable mistakes that we've made
neurotic so the solution to this problem
is maybe and other than you haven't
thought about since you're around eight
the stable Mary Ellen I'm very sorry for
the header in order to
dead men and women where each person has
ranked all members of the opposite sex
in order of preference married the men
and women together over there no two
people of opposite sex who would prefer
each other than the current partner when
there are no such pairs instead of
marriages table using things
instead of men and women i'm going to
use time open circle because HR
so if it is approved by negation so this
is an unstable so this is essentially
your circle is a Romeo and your triangle
with your Juliet and they've been
married off to someone from their own
find what they were after you right so
they will lead their partner to be with
each other and that will cause
instability in there and you'll have
some more than people on either side so
indicates were basically this try mr.
Holden silver for this triangle but long
is this triangle prefer this circle over
that one we're good because in that case
this triangle with Mike I'm not trading
out to be reserved
and I'm good where I that disables
looking they're actually able to learn
me you can't remove a stable solution so
that the algorithm is she's with Gail
seeing the algorithm we have strangled
from years ago and I will be so this is
you know ABC and theta gamma delta by
the way they fell freedom won the
democratic economics
so the first thing you do is you
basically rank all of you say I really
verbal data data is great bad as the
best record Wilson so I'm going to data
Karen who play with
mango and then delta delta only after
that end on
rank everyone whatever your criteria and
then what you have what you do you think
our bag that proposes to the other
important only one side years ago
further so we take circle Webber
building to the file in the word sound
each of the circle was going to propose
to its best it's going to go for the
gold like I have the best I can get so I
propose to the best one and then the
triangle it if you have any more
proposing three at a time if it will
take the festivities so this time we're
here you only got one hunger bowl so
it's like okay well what I got so it
takes it even though it is clearing
where assist this triangle is retreat me
to the Connecticut so it fix felt I'd
become admin is better so unfortunately
a is cold and B conveyors without to be
rejected but it will be rejected okay so
I got to a degree let's get going so
then beta now gives it another go when
it tries for a second but not the
biggest second does mother Queen B & B
now seeing that it
when I can trade out I actually prefer
beta over gamma so instead of I die
Ghana and it's now the cool again we
keep going and so there's a one-to-one
mapping
proposals to accept in America that is
human
any questions about that probably a lot
of you know this algorithm from your
algorithms for something the rest of us
done too much time in profitable
mechanics could not get luxury so I
visited that bad look a couple things in
our journalists are believed you had to
ring foster care so we have the buzzer
in week 1 and clustering at me too how
do you raise the interplay between these
clusters of the closest that we map one
buster they want hurt Elizabeth we be
able to write a scale for 100 million
little boy
and into running beverages and we need
the old handle things went ties and we
all have to be able to handle what i
call the CNN projected Donald Trump
effective November where large household
all huge again we plus their full sails
in the theory and comfortable so I
assume there will be some trouble of
inconvenience will also be here but have
you forgotten so
turns out with them you can serve and we
went from 78,000
two ninety-eight percent tell people
love the 90 and really thought about it
so now actually sell it just last week
will be seen once persistent crossword
items in our data box and it turns out
we went from eight without having 30
now almost at ninety percent o r8e
consistency thank you our graph is built
on without a visa data that means almost
no data overlap between being used to
build around it sound better than one so
the conclusions east island Republic sir
latest magazine and they were not Davis
came from their engineering problem
unfortunately the high desert ago are
not always needed to hear this include
me but it would have been rated by new
music algorithms of rent go and so we're
speaking to the choir I get you require
it is i just knew more of engineering
algorithms we can be considered an
assignment your phone has to know the
problem that up that are not a design
problem instead of building some
horrible detection algorithm to do this
I wrote in he'll develop the scholarship
more open and once you start seeing this
you start stable matching everything so
anything that you can have like a
massive you can seamless and we need a
one-to-one nothing good anytime you have
anything where you have pairs of things
so for example you build a correlation
matrix and you want to find clusters of
the whole you think you can run a
connected component awkward
very smart so these problems are deep
algorithm
the problem that i developed so many
awful things and in fact since we've
developed these algorithms here nestle
used both of them early three or four
you see her persistent not just
Christian cross training but now
actually using or persistent demaizen
been looking at it for another twenty
percent times and preparing come on you
know this right on track or in it on our
device identifiers and also correlations
between therapies parts so i really want
to think that is I didn t routine
because it really helps everything year
and they actually done a lot of this
work they have a lot of my work we have
jobs even stolen just please come come
work for Devon although i'm in your
fears if there's a lot because there you
know
kind of like and follow after you can
follow me on twitter you will i Candi
what kind of David Lee yeah so weak
Alyssa the standard and techie did
request your data will do things like
user agent device ID URL that your
brother home times down take a breath
basic ad tech
which libraries can be used to
no Viper is here scalding elaborate but
everything here is actually written in
scalding pretty basic scalding not
there's no no data library
over
you know there are other than is
probabilistic so we don't really know
for sure that any
correct so with occasionally
accidentally bridge to Euler's our
algorithm makes a miracle covenant that
productive members and if it gets
corrected because that the data goes
away our next 14
that would be an assumed that get hurt
you